hallo melis
hallo andreas
wie geht es dir
mir geht es super
mehr geht es super
wie geht es dir
[Musik]
mir geht es so lala
ich fühle mich ein bisschen schwach
hast du gehst acht stunden geschlafen
man sollte jeden acht stunden schlafen
hast du gestern acht stunden geschlafen
man soll jeden tag acht stunden schlafen
oh nein ich habe etwa sechs stunden
geschlafen
schlaf mehr
und hast du gestern zwei liter wasser
getrunken
nein ich habe etwa einen liter getrunken
trinkt mehr wasser
[Musik]
und hast du letzte woche sport gemacht
ja ich habe sport gemacht
wie oft
ich habe letzte woche zweimal im
fitnessstudio trainiert
das ist gut
man soll sich genug bewegen
bis du gestern
die frische luft gegangen
nein gestern habe ich den ganzen tag
drinnen im home-office gearbeitet
bis du gestern
die frische luft gegangen
nein gestern habe ich den ganzen tag
drinnen im home-office gearbeitet
ich habe mindestens acht stunden
gearbeitet
das ist nicht gut
du sollst mehr an die frische luft gehen
und a
weniger
[Musik]
das ist nicht gut
du sollst mehr an die frische luft gehen
und ab
ja
[Musik]
hast du letzte woche geraucht
nein ich rauche nicht
das ist prima
hast du letzte woche geraucht
nein ich rauche nicht
das ist prima
und wie sieht s mit alkohol aus
hast du letzte woche alkohol getrunken
und wie sieht er mit alkohol aus
ja ich war am mittwoch und am freitag in
einer bar
ich habe bier getrunken
ja ich war am mittwoch und am freitag in
einer bar
ich habe bier getrunken
trinkt weniger alkohol
ok vielen dank für die tipps und
ratschläge
ich werde versuchen mehr zu schlafen und
weniger zu arbeiten
ich höre auf bier zu trinken und werde
regelmäßiger sport machen
ok vielen dank für die tipps und
ratschläge
ich werde versuchen mehr zu schlafen und
weniger zu arbeiten
ich höre auf bier zu trinken und werde
regelmäßiger sport machen
das ist gut
ich hoffe dass es
bald besser geht
das ist gut
ich hoffe dass es mir bald besser geht
du musst auf dich ein
das ist wichtig
du musst auf dich schauen
du hast recht
so ich muss los mein bus fährt in vier
minuten
ok ich wünsche dir einen schönen tag
tschüss und
alt
ok ich wünsche dir einen schönen tag
tschüss und
alt
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare
wir werden sie beantworten
hast du eine frage schreibt eine frage
in die kommentare wir werden sie
beantworten
möchtest du gratis online deutsch lernen
mehr als 200 video lektionen abonniere
unseren kanal möchtest du gratis online
deutsch lernen mehr als 200 video
lektionen abonniere unseren kanal